how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and ever since we got the secret
Invasion finale a couple of days ago
Marvel fans have had a lot of questions
like what exactly is Gaia going to be up
to now that she's pretty much the
strongest character in the Marvel
Universe at least that we know of so far
what's going on with Nick Fury what's
going on with his wife and that X-Men
Easter egg that we discovered there are
a lot of questions right now but of
course the biggest question that fans
are asking right now is when did Roadie
become a scroll when did the scroll rava
take over rhodey's life there have
already been a lot of theories and
predictions about this and a lot of them
make sense but it looks like Marvel
Studios is doing something very specific
when it comes to answering this question
and what they're actually doing is kind
of not being specific at all but there
is a very intentional reason for this
now recently in an interview with
comicbook.com the director of secret
Invasion Ali Salem did actually address
when Roadie becomes a scroll he does
give a definitive answer of when but he
gives a two-part answer that also leaves
some stuff open and of course we're
gonna break the whole thing down and
explain what you need to know including
what we think Marvel's specific plan is
for this and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news or breakdowns and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so of course everybody is asking
questions right now about Roadie when he
became a scroll a lot of people think it
could be after Civil War and a lot of
people who think that could be right in
an interview with comicbook.com secret
Invasion director Ali selum said this a
lot of people have asked about
definitively when did Roadie implying
when did roadie become scroll when did
rava take over he continued to say I
think his legs not working in the end of
episode 6 and him being in the hospital
gown points to Captain America Civil War
so this statement right here would tell
us that Roadie is wearing the same
hospital gown that we saw him in at the
end of Civil War the exact same one as
far as the internet can tell we have
found zero differences in these two
hospital gowns they look to be exactly
the same so the director here is telling
us that this is the same gown and the
fact that it's the same gown points to
Captain America Civil War heavily
implying that this is when Roadie was
switched with a scroll he also talks
about his legs not working and of course
after the events of Civil War rhodey's
legs didn't work we saw him begin the
process of physical therapy we also saw
that he had some Iron Man Tech on his
legs helping him walk and we assumed
that over the years he got better at
walking on his own and possibly relied
Less on the technology although in
Avengers Infinity War we do still see
that he is wearing the devices on his
legs that help him walk but the director
here is implying that since Roadie
cannot walk he's implying that this is
the Roadie that got injured in Civil War
and didn't really have any physical
therapy because it was the scroll doing
that the entire time now this would be a
definitive answer and he states that
people want a definitive answer but then
he goes on to kind of give a part two to
this question after he says I think his
legs not working in the end of episode 6
and him being in the hospital gown
points to Captain America's Civil War he
says this and from there does it have to
be definitive or is it more fun for the
audience to go back and revisit every
moment every Roadie moment and look at
it with a different lens now that they
think oh he might have been a scroll
there and make the decision for
themselves or it'll be answered in armor
Wars so he goes from giving a definitive
answer to giving pretty much the most
vague answer you can get and here's the
deal I think that Marvel is doing this
on purpose and the reason I think
they're doing this on purpose is because
I don't think they actually know which
direction they want to go but it almost
does sound like they are retconning
Roadie story in the MCU because I don't
think that this was the plan at any
point in time I don't think 10 years ago
five years ago when in-game came out
this was the plan I don't think it was
ever a plan for Roadie to be a scroll
but when they decided that sacred
invasion was going to be a Disney Plus
show and that they were going to reveal
that some of the Avengers that we knew
this entire time were scroll I think
that's when the retcon started they went
well we could say Rhodey was a scroll
the entire time because he's in a high
position of power in the government he
was a pretty big character he's part of
the main cast in some movies but he's
not one of the original main Avengers so
it's not that big of a slap in the face
to fans whereas it would be if we said
Iron Man was a scroll the entire time or
black widow was a scroll the entire time
I believe that's why they picked Roadie
he was big enough but not part of the
main Ensemble of the Avengers team and
his high position of power in the United
States government made it make sense for
them to choose him as a scroll because a
scroll would want to infiltrate a
position of power so really I think
there are two options here one Marvel is
indeed retconning the story of roadie
which will in turn negate some things
that we've seen happen and I'll explain
these things in just a bit but if they
do retcon roady's story they'll say much
like the director hinted at that that
Roadie has been a scroll since the
events of Civil War the second option is
that they can say that Roadie was taken
after Avengers endgame now if you have a
preference of which option you'd like to
be true please let us know why and which
one in the comments down below him being
to scroll after Civil War or him being a
Scroll after Avengers end game here's
the problem and here's why it would have
to be a complete retcon there are some
continuity points that they would have
to kind of ignore one is that we have
seen Roadie without any support on his
legs without any type of War Machine
armor or Tony Stark Tech on his legs not
being able to walk we saw this in
Avengers end game when the Avengers
headquarters got taken down Roadie had
to get out of a suit and he had to crawl
he could not use his legs this heavily
implies that this is indeed the real
Roadie why would rava at that time in a
life or death situation still continue
to act like she is roadie and cannot use
her legs if it's life or death for her
she's gonna use her legs and get up and
she could just have found a way to
explain it oh at the time my adrenaline
was kicking in and all of a sudden I got
strength back in my legs because I was
fighting for my life that's what she
could have said as Roadie but instead we
see Roadie crawling because he cannot
use his legs this tells us that this was
indeed Roadie that's why if they did say
that rava took over right after the
events of Civil War it would have to be
a retcon in the MCU another reason is a
big reason that my buddy Paul over at
heavy spoilers brought up in a recent
video of his he explains that gravic was
still working for Nick Fury after
Avengers endgame he was one of the
skrull who helped collect the blood
samples the DNA samples on the
battlefield after the big fight this
implies that grabbeck and Nick Fury were
still good so that means they might not
have had rebelled yet they might not
have taken over positions in the
government yet meaning rava might not
have taken over as a rhodi yet it's a
great point that Paul makes and it seems
like from what we have learned in the
series that graphic and the rest of the
scroll didn't really become irritated
with Nick Fury until after everyone came
back you can't really blame Nick Fury
for being snapped it wasn't his choice
it wasn't his fault but after he came
back from the blip he went up to saber
and never came back and didn't do
anything that's when the scroll started
to get irritated and betrayed by Nick
Fury that is when rabbit kind of took
everything into his own hands with the
rest of the scroll Rebellion so this
would have to be another retcon but
again I think that Marvel Studios is
kind of waiting to feel out the
situation I think that they haven't
really decided what to do yet I had the
opportunity to speak with director Ali
Salem as well this was when I had only
seen the first two episodes of secret
Invasion but I asked him if any previous
show or movie or any upcoming show or
movie had affected the story for secret
Invasion and he said no he said that he
did his own thing they made the story
that they wanted to make now of course
everything has to go by Kevin feige but
again like I stated before in the moment
I think they went oh yeah it would make
sense for Roadie to be a scroll let's go
with that and Don Cheadle even talked
about this he said oh yeah when they
came up with that idea they called me in
to talk about it and I went oh yeah this
would be cool it would be cool to play
kind of a different Roadie so I think at
the time that was all they thought about
that was their plan and then of course
they thought well fans are gonna wonder
how long has already been a scroll for
and perhaps they didn't have an answer
to that at the time because they went
well it could be many points we're still
riding armor Wars right now so let's
wait a little bit to decide we don't
have to decide right away and I think
that's why the director said in this
interview or you'll find out in armor
Wars I think you said that pretty
Ambiguously because he himself doesn't
really know possibly because Marvel
Studios doesn't exactly have an answer
for us yet but the first part of his
answer does make it seem like they might
have gone with the fact that Roadie is
wearing the same gown because that is
put in the finale that is in the episode
he's wearing the same gown so it looks
like Marvel Studios could have gone with
the decision of yeah he's been a scroll
since Civil War in which case that means
some of these scenes with Tony Stark and
the rest of the Avengers might not mean
as much and if that is the case let us
know your thoughts about that in the
comments down below how do you feel
about that which would you prefer him
being a scroll since Civil War or him
being a scroll since after Avengers
endgame leave all your thoughts down
below also don't forget to leave a like
And subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos you can also find us on patreon
you can check out our website and our
Discord server and of course you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof